PROFESSOR: So I want
to go a little further
to try to put resonances in
a more intriguing footing.
That you can play with and if
you-- at some point interested.
So let's think of discovering
[INAUDIBLE] that we have.
We had A s--
remember the scattered wave was
A s e to the ikx [INAUDIBLE]
that divided 2.
And what was A s?
Well, A s squared--
the sine square delta.
So if you remember this was
sine delta e to the i delta.
So let's stick to that and try
to write it in a funny way.
Certainly, A s is becoming
large near resonance,
so let's think when
A s becomes large.
Well, in another way let's be
a little creative about things,
It's good sometimes
not to be logical.
So let's write this
as sine delta--
I'll do it here--
sine delta over e to
the minus i of delta .
And that's sine delta over
close delta minus i sine delta.
That's all good.
A s-- let me divide by
sine delta both sides--
both numerator and denominator.
So-- no divide it
by cosine delta,
so I'll have tan delta
over 1 minus i tan delta.
I divide it by cosine.
You want A s large?
You really want it
large, choose tan delta--
equals to minus i.
Sounds crazy, but
it's not really crazy.
The reason it sounds crazy and
it's somewhat strange and not
very logical is tan
delta is a phase
and the tangent of any phase
is never an imaginary number.
So then I would have
think of delta itself
as a complex number.
And what would that mean.
So things are weird.
But it's certainly the fact
that A s will become infinite--
not just large-- but infinite.
A s will become infinite.
And you say, wow, this
doesn't make any sense.
But maybe it makes sense
in the following way.
This is the line of
real phase shifts.
[INAUDIBLE] are real.
And here is the world
of complex phase shifts.
These are the real phase shifts
and there are the complex phase
shifts.
Maybe if the phase
shift becomes infinite--
off the real axis--
it's just large
on the real axis.
So actually, if you
wanted it to be very large
you would have to get
off the real axis.
If this sounds vague,
it is still vague.
But in a minute we'll
make it precise.
So I suggest that we take
this idea seriously--
that maybe this means something.
And we can try to argue
that by looking back
at what resonances do.
So what I will do is look with
[INAUDIBLE] a resonance here--
tangent delta.
So let's look at what A s does.
We have it there.
A s is tan delta--
well, tan delta--
we had it in the
middle of blackboard
is beta over alpha
minus k, 1 minus i beta
over alpha minus k, again.
So that's how A s
behaves in general.
That's fine, there's no -- at
this moment there's nothing
crazy about this.
Because this is
something you all agreed,
nobody complained
about this formula.
So A s is given
by that formula--
that's also legal math, so far.
So we'll have this.
And then let's simplify
it a little bit which
is beta over alpha
minus k minus i beta.
So this still beta over
alpha minus i beta minus k.
So we usually would plot
A s as a function of k.
That's what we're trying to
do, it's a function of k.
And now here is the formula
for A s as the function of k.
And here is k.
But let's be daring now
and not say this is k,
this is the complex k-plane.
And yes, you work with
real k, but that's
because that has a direct
physical interpretation.
But maybe the complex
plane has a more subtle
physical interpretation
and that's
what they claim
is happening here.
This quantity becomes
infinite near the resonance.
Here was the resonance,
what you call the resonance.
But this becomes really
infinite not at alpha--
for when k is equal
to alpha, but when k
is equal to alpha minus i beta.
Beta was supposed to be
small for a resonance.
So here is minus i beta and
here is this very unusual point.
Where the scattering
amplitude blows up.
It has what is in
complex variables--
if you've taken 1806
it's called a pole.
In a complex variable
when you have
a denominator that vanishes
linearly we call it a pole.
Things blow up.
So this carrying amplitude
has a pole off the real axis.
And interpretation is correct.
At this point, this
function becomes infinite.
And what is happening
on the real line
that A s is becoming
large is just
the remnant of that
infinity over here
that is affecting the
value of this point.
So in the complex plane
you understand the function
a little better.
You see why it's
becoming big and you
can see also with a
little [INAUDIBLE]
why the phases
shifting very fast
because you have this point.
And that's called the resonance.
And this is the
mathematically precise way
of searching for resonances.
If you want to search for
resonances what you should do
is you have your formula for
delta as a function of k.
I mean, it's a
complicated formula,
but now try to solve the
equation tan delta of this
is equal to minus
i because that's
what guarantees
that you have a pole
that indeed it blows
up at some value.
That's where A s blows up which
we see directly here-- it's
this value.
Alpha minus i beta, so alpha
minus i beta is a pole of A s.
And therefore, you must be
happening when tangent of delta
is equal to minus i.
So you have a very
complicated formula
maybe for tangent of delta.
But set it equal to minus
i and asked mathematically
to solve it.
And a number will come--
k a equal 2.73 minus 0.003.
And you will know-- oh, that's
a resonance, it's off the axis.
And the real part is
the value of alpha.
And since this is beta
the closer to the axis --
if you find more--
the more resonant it is.
And by the time it's
far from the axis,
some people call it the
resonance-- some people say,
no that not the resonance.
It's a matter of taste.
But there are important
things which are these poles.
So I will not give
you exercises on that,
but you may want
to try it if you
want to have some entertainment
with these things.
I want to say one
more thing about this.
And it's the reason why this
viewpoint is interesting,
as well.
We already found that if we
want to think of resonances more
precisely.
We can think of them
as just an equation.
You solve for the equation,
so that it gives you
the resonance.
And this is the
equation you must solve
and you must admit complex k.
But now you can say,
look actually you
have e is equal to h
squared, k squared, over 2m.
And we have real k's--
this is the physical
scattering solutions,
complex k's, also resonances.
How about imaginary k's?
If k is equal to i kappa--
kappa belonging to
the real numbers--
then the energy becomes minus
h squared, kappa squared,
over 2m and its less
than zero and it
could represent bound states.
So you'll be then discovering
solutions of real k
representing your waves.
Now mathematically, you
are led to resonances
understood as poles
in the scattering
amplitutde we did here.
We see that k's in
the imaginary axis
would represent bound states.
So the complex
k-plane is very rich.
It has room for your
scattering solutions,
it has room for your
resonance, it even
has room for your bound states.
They're all there.
That's why it's a
valuable extension.
I have now proven for you
that bound states correspond
to poles.
It's a simple calculation, and
that I would assign it to you
with a little bit of guidance.
And you will see that also
for the case of bound states,
you get a pole in the
scattering amplitude,
and that will complete the
interpretation of that.
Now people go a little
further, actually,
and they invent
poles in this part
and they're called
anti-bound states.
And you'll say, what's that?
If you have a bound state
you match a solution
to a pure decaying exponential
for the [INAUDIBLE] region.
In an anti-bound bound state
you match your solution
to a pure increasing
exponential.
A pure one.
Does that have an
interpretation?
It actually does
have interpretation.
Some nuclear states
are associated
with anti-bound states.
So the mathematical
description--
the rich complex
plane is ready for you
if you just do
scattering amplitude k,
resonances-- complex k.
Normal bound states,
imaginary k-- positive.
Anti-bounds is negative k.
It's a nice start.